our next guest is considered to be one
of the least athletic members of his own
family his father ed won multiple Super
Bowls his mother Lisa was a soccer stars
uncle Billy won a national title in
basketball Duke meanwhile our guest came
in second in the Heisman race he didn't
even win Rookie of the Year honors with
the Panthers despite these failures his
parents are hopeful that his little
brothers will soon be in the NFL to
restore the family name please welcome
Christian
[Applause]
what's up guys
[Music]
[Applause]
expect like we're gonna say something
nice about them when they come in by the
way nice part in the hair looking good
Greg Olson taught me this Greg Olson
taught you how to part your hair Oh
buddy gasses my hair up more than Greg
Olson no what do you mean gases up like
he complements
oh he complements excessively alright is
this story true that when you were born
your mom cried because she wanted a girl
very true yeah she told me that when I
first heard the story she said yeah I
cried when you were born
that's really sweet favorite child like
no because I knew that I was never gonna
get a girl so that was that was Wow not
great now are you were you called
Christian because if it was a girl was
the girl gonna be called Christian as
well or how about I have no idea I asked
these it's a family name I stopped after
she said I cried I didn't want the
second best sport growing up was what I
loved basketball I played hoops my whole
life if you could play basketball now in
the NBA yeah instead of football see
your starting point guard for the oh
yeah wait you're with Greer with Jordans
team
yeah so if you're with your over but I'm
a big I was gonna say if you're gonna be
the Nuggets or or the hole so if I said
your starting point guard in the NBA for
the next ten years
nah I'd still choose are you sure yeah
are you saying that just because that's
the right thing but did you did you
plays in the NBA the way you played in
high school
oh I'm gonna Russell Westbrook for sure
that was my game in high school floor
general managed the court really same
same amount of bounce I would like to
say I didn't pass your a Gunnar Kyle
Korver was my idol I'll say that but I I
love Kyle Korver I can't shoot like him
so I was pretty much a passer slash
defensive specialist which is what most
football guys that played basketball
said early near I'd foul out every games
that's kind of why coming from from
football like you were physical yeah
yeah when did you know you were good in
football oh pretty early on it say
Little League I never like hit me but
you know and literally god I'd always we
had a really good team so I think I was
an intricate part of that team and I
knew early on that football is what I
wanted to do pretty much when I was
seven did mom care if you played mushy
nervous now she was never nervous
I played my older brother started
playing so I would beg them to play they
never really forced it upon me or made
me do anything it was really what I I
wanted to do and so I was dying to play
football I wanted to do it ever since I
saw my brother play it and so pretty
early on they let me suit up and I think
seven did you get a chance to see your
dad at all play yeah when I was little I
don't remember a whole lot of it I
watched I watched the old NFL tapes to
see them play dead your dad got roughed
up yeah he did I mean even in there
until did yeah I took shots yeah he did
so it's really cool though being able to
look back on some of the pictures and
the memories of but you didn't wanna be
a wide receiver no and seeing literally
the wide receivers never got the ball it
doesn't change in the NFL all right okay
the style offense you guys are you're
playing now is it based off the Patriots
style of offense I don't know if it's
based off any single team I think coach
Turner obviously you look at his history
and what he's done with offenses you
know he's had multiple number one
offenses in the league because I was
told that you were trying to make it
easier for cam so completion percentages
a little bit more dink and dunk than
throwing deeper down the field bringing
you in
Curtis Samuel so I'm gonna have guys out
of the backfield and that was gonna be
the style but it's not based off of what
Tom's doing in New England I think it's
it's I mean I I think it's definitely
had an influence I wouldn't say that's
our base you know we want to develop a
run game and obviously football huge
team game I don't I wouldn't say it's
completely on cam or you know for cam we
want to get a lot of guys involved and
so happens with our
personnel that those those check downs
and those short passes end up working
welfare for everybody for camphor for me
and for our office in general when's the
last time you talked to camp talked to
him yesterday how's he doing he's doing
well he's now could he pick up the phone
with his right hand
oh he could yeah so the shoulders okay
yeah he I mean he's an unbelievably hard
worker man okay he's doing everything
possible to make sure now we do this
from time to time he drew breezes to all
the greats have done it
JJ wants done it Aaron Rodgers drew
brees I mentioned it's your draft
profile okay
now I took out the good stuff you did
yeah
good I don't want to hear the good okay
so here you go this is your draft
profile I want you to read your draft
profile Christian McCaffrey this was
said about you as you're getting ready
to come out of Stanford all right this
one lacks desired size of an every down
back takes foot off gas in the contact
doesn't have NFL caliber power to break
tackles and create yardage for himself
pin shake tacklers but lacks a twitchy
burst to accelerate away after the cut
slow like what do you want to be a buddy
whose twitch is shortened that did this
short yeah when she could get lost in
the mix if he goes to a team is
unwilling to be creative and tap into
his versatile skill set okay
is that a shot at like a character is
that a character shot no I get lost seem
unwilling to be okay and I get that he
ducks his head too much when he is going
to make contact which could shorten his
career okay how did we do with any of
those oh you wait are you gonna rip them
up don't rip them up no no you should I
keep you know what drew brees kept I'm
gonna keep this Brees kept his to JJ
Watt kept his and Bree said I'm gonna
put at my locker and I'm gonna I'm gonna
look at it every single game so yeah I
do love that we also I know you love
music but we were
we were trying to gauge if you could
dance now you can't dance no or you
won't dance
both okay say both joining us on behalf
of Wounded Warriors Project and if you'd
like to mention that before we say
goodbye yes it's been a it's been a fun
week got a partner with us a and Wounded
Warrior Project and being able to send a
few military members out here sergeant
Summerson and his wife Shawna who's also
military so being in North Carolina big
military community it's been been a good
week so I'm excited to meet them later
in the week
obviously with USA being the official
sponsor of the NFL and hosting service
program so this Saturday Christian is
scheduled to meet with several military
guests at the USA a salute to service
military appreciation lounge you were a
great sport you had a great season and
you'll have a great career please tell
your parents I set a low certainly your
father and thank you for stopping by I
appreciate you guys have anything for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]